each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
Center for reliable and high-performance
computing the title of my talk today is
enhancing security of real-world systems
with a better understanding of threat so
before getting into the main body of my
talk I would first like to give an
overview of my research experiences my
dissertation the focus of my
dissertation is security threat analysis
and litigations in real-world systems
broadly I want to answer three questions
first how errors how errors in hardware
and software imposed security threat to
reward systems can we identify any
common characteristics among security
threat and secondly how effective our
current defense techniques are there any
substantial deficiencies in in our
currency defense techniques and finally
how can we build better defense
techniques so I think the then I think
the most unique aspect of my research is
the analysis centric research approach
so I spend a large amount of time
throughout these years to analyze a
security security threat in real systems
in my first two papers I start out we
started hardware memory errors in order
to to evaluate their impact on system
security and then then we try to
understand software vulnerabilities so
we did an extensive analysis on
backtrack and the third vulnerable
vulnerable ed databases as well as a
large amount of source code of wonderful
applications then recently we focus on
the analysis of current attack method
and and defense techniques the goal of
all these analysis is to expose new
security threat which motivate us to
develop few defense techniques but many
areas in computer science are related to
my dissertation
including security dependability and
formal method operating system and
programming language the piece besides
the research in Illinois I also have
several system hacking experiences in
industrial labs the the first the first
project in a vile ABS was to put lip
save to Windows system the lip save is a
software package originally designed for
linux to defeat buffer overflow attacks
then in summer 2002 my project in Bell
Labs was to to hack freebsd tcp/ip
implementation and the network network
card drivers in order to detect and
defeat network denial of service attacks
then I did my first MSR internship with
dan Simon of audit enhanced
authentication in covers the this
project requires modifications on
Windows kernel security subsystem covers
and local security authority and entity
err error and last summer I work with
jang donggun chat for boskie and anyone
to develop a tracing technique to
identify the dependencies of Windows
applications on administrators privilege
and this project requires a substantial
development work on security windows
kernel security subsystem access and
privilege checking as well as a good
understanding of application interaction
with Windows Windows kernel so uh so
those are interesting project that I
want to talk to you during our
one-on-one meetings but in this talk I
would like to focus on my dissertation
now the first part of the the talk will
be focused on analyzing and identify
security threat on real-world systems so
our first briefly illustrate how the
security of real systems can be
compromised
due to hardware and software of memory
errors then our our analysis on many
real security vulnerabilities indicate
that a type of memory corruption attacks
currently believed to be rare is in fact
a realistic threat to the system then I
with this then I will discuss how this
finding affect the effectiveness of many
current events techniques then in
response to the new threat we proposed
new defense techniques towards a better
security protection so in the second
part of the talk I will define a program
behavior which which we call the pointer
daintiness which is the common
characteristic of memory corruption
attacks are based on pointer daintiness
we built a theorem proving based program
analysis technique and a runtime
detection technique to defeat most
memory corruption attacks so now please
now I start my first part analyzing and
identifying security threat of real
world system the it is widely known that
hardware memory errors can cause
dependability problems for example
system crash or erroneous computations
we we are interested to know how likely
that hardware memory errors can cause
security problems so we emulated random
hardware errors and evaluate their
impact of security for example when
there is an error in the user space then
the authentication can be can be
bypassed the authentication of ftp and
ssh can be bypassed so that and an
attacker can get into the server and we
also observe that if there is an error
in the linux kernel malicious packet can
penetrate the firewall without being
detected
so these these indicate that with a
non-negligible probability real systems
the security of real systems can be
compromised due to random hardware
errors that according to to our
experiment that is usually from point a
point five percent to two percent in
depth yes yes
opponent
okay okay yeah so I submit this is an
interesting work which motivate
researchers in another University to
actually conduct physical for the
injection experiment they are able to
show that the Java type system can be
completely separated due to random
hardware errors they actually use a
spotlight to to heat to heat CPU to
introduce physical memory errors and
they are able to show that Java system
can be subverted so now now let's let's
talk about the software vulnerabilities
because although hardware memory errors
are potential security threat the most
eminent security vulnerabilities are due
to software bugs so then are our
statistics on set at the visor ease but
by the way this is a vulnerability
database our statistic statistics shows
that over sixty-six percent of
vulnerabilities are due to low level
memory errors which include a buffer
overflow integer overflow keep
corruption format string vulnerabilities
and recent global abilities so these
vulnerabilities are widely exploited by
articles worms and viruses let let's see
an example this is a classic attack
against a Washington University ftp
server so first of when the user when
the attacker authenticated to the server
the server is running as as regular user
then the attacker when the server gets
into the service loop the attacker can
embed malicious content in the input
which is later used by a function printf
and at this point at this point the
attacker get a chance to overwrite an
arbitrary memory location so in this
case the attacker can override a return
address to hijack the control flow in
order to run a piece of
malicious code so by calling set
effective you id0 and exec being SH the
attacker get a root shell so very sick
very similarly to attack an HTTP server
program the attacker can first overflow
a heap buffer which corrupt the heap
structure then when this buffer is later
freed the attacker get a chance to
overwrite and memory location in this
case the attacker can overwrite a
function pointer to hijack the control
flow and still the attacker get the root
privilege now the the underlying
principle of all these attacks is to
exploit a memory memory corruption
vulnerability in order to corrupt
control data to hijack the control by
control data I mean very specifically
the data used as target of call return
and drop they are widely understood as
security critical elements so according
to cert and microsoft security bulletin
control data attack is the most dominant
form of memory corruption attacks so and
so accordingly many current defense
techniques are designed to enforce
program control control flow integrity
in order to provide security for example
many intrusion detection systems are
based on a system called monitoring two
to detect any anomalies of your program
behaviors in terms of us our system
across sequences and also some other
techniques strictly prevent you from
overwriting any control data but all
these techniques are effective against
control data attacks on the other hand
however that attacks not corrupting any
control data or we can say non control
data attacks they are currently very
rare in reality we are aware of a number
of instances suggested in the leader
for example one instance suggested by
young and McHugh in 1987 however there
is no study to understand how applicable
are such attacks against the real-world
systems but that is a very important
question because this may affect this
may affect the effectiveness of our
current defense techniques so in fact
the general applicability of non control
data attacks depends on whether
attackers are really incapable to mount
such attacks against many real systems
so based on our previous hardware for
the injection experiment we have seen
that even a memory error it is it is
likely that the memory that the security
of real system can be compromised so so
maybe the attacker the attackers
capability is more powerful than we are
assuming currently so input in
particular we know that we know even
random hardware errors can subvert the
security and compared to hardware memory
errors software vulnerabilities are more
deterministic and more amenable to
attacks in addition we have seen that
each attack exploiting software
vulnerabilities can be decomposed to
multiple primitive components just like
a sequence of here's where you can
assemble the attack allow you to
construct a polymorphic attacks so in
other words the current attacks
overriding control data can be easily
transformed to attack not corrupting any
control data by exploiting the same
vulnerability so based on this insight
we claim that many real-world software
applications are susceptible to
non-controlled Atta attacks and the
severity of the attack consequences is
equivalent to that due to control data
attacks now of course we need to
validate this claim because now we are
not talking about hardware fault
injection we are talking about purely
software software attacks this claim is
validated by by constructing non control
data attacks to get the route through
village on major network servers
including FTP HTTP SSH and telnet
servers we found that vulnerabilities in
these types of server applications
account for over one third of
vulnerabilities insert advisories so
these are reasonably representative set
of real applications so the importance
of our claim is that it clearly
indicated that non control data attacks
are realistic threat so let's see let's
see some real examples again Washington
University ftp server this is the most
widely used ftp server there is a format
stream bug that there is a format string
bag when you call this function get ftp
command now all existing or existing
attacks are control data attacks and in
our study we found a way to get the root
privilege of ftp server while still
preserving the control flow integrity so
the challenge the challenge of us as as
attackers is that when when the user
when the user authenticate to the server
and the in here we have a integer X
which is the user ID of the
authenticated user so in this case
assuming X is 109 which is the regular
user ID then the server our cause set
steady you ID to drop the privilege to
the regular users privilege so now the
question is how can we are exploit the
vulnerability to get the root privilege
oh then
to get the root of privilege after this
point so what we can do is first we send
a special site exact command which can
trigger the format string vulnerability
to overwrite integer X 20 and after that
we can we force the program to go
through a very specific execution past
eventually the function get data sock
will be invoked then in in the function
get data sock the privilege of the
process needs to be temporarily elevated
in order to in order to make this system
call because this is privileged system
call and after that the function tries
to drop the privilege to the regular
users privilege however since we have
already overwritten x20 the this
function call does not drop the
privilege so when the server returns to
the service loop it is still running as
root allowing me to upload an arbitrary
file including et Cie password so i can
overwrite this file which means i can
grant it myself this is exploiting not
far enough over yeah yeah the idea is
this but in this particular case it is
formats stream bug which allows you to
specify a memory location to write that
yeah % n yeah exactly okay so so so we
can grunt I can grunt myself the root
privilege and as you can see that
throughout the entire attack process I
do not overwrite any control data but
only the integer X so this is not a
control hijacking attack and to attack
an HTTP HTTP server we found that
overwriting only four characters of all
plain text characters is sufficient to
get
the root privilege so we in this attack
we corrupt the configuration string of
CGI theme pass now what is DJ CGI is
standard interface for client to execute
a piece of two to execute a set of
pre-selected executables on the server
side so and the cgi bin cgi being is the
specifies the root directory of the
executables that that you can run so any
executables outside cgi being past
cannot be executed suppose in this case
suppose to the server name is www comp
and the CDI beam is a user local HD DVD
exe then when the client make this URL
request the server will first take a the
CGI pin configuration append by slash
bar to run this file on the server so
you can realize the importance of the
integrity of cgi bin our attack is to
exploit the heap overflow back to
overwrite cgi bin to slash be so that
when i make another this request the
server will execute a slash bin slash at
sh s s root which still give me the
route / village so I only corrupt I only
corrupted a cgi bin stream from from
this string to this stream so this is
not a control flow height up cut control
data attack another example a real
example is a widely used ssh server
developed by ssh communications there is
the integer overflow integer overflow
back to in this file but in this
function sorry so we observe that there
is a stack integer oz which which is a
flag to indicate whether the user has
the user has succeeded in the
authentication
but initially oz is 0 then the server
tries to authenticate the user so in
this case for example when i try to send
the password this function will be to
vote however but so of course I I do not
have the correct password however I can
exploit the vulnerability at this point
to overwrite us 21 and after that the
server will will break out of the
authentication and let me get in without
correct password and more examples
include the default telnet server of red
hat linux where we we can override two
strings from login to SH around this to
Dash P then we can get the root
privilege also to attack another HTTP
server we can exploit a stack buffer
overflow bug in order to embed malicious
content a slashdot in the in the URL and
once you can embed slashdot in your URL
you can you can execute any files on the
server side so so the the success of all
this experiment clearly showed clearly
shows that control flow integrity is not
a sufficiently accurate up with
approximation to software security and
so you may notice that usually non non
control data attacks are very specific
to application semantics for example the
cgi bin the CGI being attack does not
work for ftp server it only works for
HTTP server however in our study we
found that many types of non control
data are critical to security which can
be overwritten by by attackers therefore
this is the danger once attackers have
the incentive they are likely to succeed
in non control data attack
and so so being aware of the general
applicability of non control data attack
we now re-examine current defense
techniques we found that many of them
are based on control flow integrity for
example that they either our monitor
system called system code sequences or
they protect the control data from being
tampered with or they implement
non-taxable stack and heap all these
techniques are effective against
traditional attacks but not none control
non control data attacks now another
another techniques is pointer encryption
but this technique currently it can only
protect pointers at the application
level and and as you can see that in in
my previous attacks none of them
overwrite any any pointer at the
application level but which means in
order for this technique to be effective
at least it has to encrypt
oh I'm sorry as I know in my case the
example of stack buffer overflow I only
over right within the current function
frame I do not exceed the boundary
because if I are over right through the
return address I will be caught so I
have to restrict myself within a current
yeah so so in order for this technique
to be effective at least it has to
encrypt pointers at C library level to
defeat the attack however that is very
challenging because at C library level
usually there is no sufficient type
information and the type casting is very
often and more importantly in in lipsy
performance is a critical issue which
prevent you from doing encryption and
decryption very often and then another
technique is a address space
randomization that this is a good idea
which forces program program memory
layout to be always different in each
one of the process however it is also
challenging to deploy this technique in
each member gram segment so currently
people are still implementing this idea
segment by segment moreover even when
address address space randomization can
be deployed to every program segment a
reason I pay a recent paper in the CCS
conference shows that the deployment of
this technique on 32-bit architecture
does not provide a sufficient entropy to
defeat a brute force attacks
and finally the the techniques like
staggered leap save and format guard
their effectiveness are not affected by
nine control data text however these
these techniques are very specific to
stack buffer overflow and format string
attacks they are not generic solutions
therefore we argue that building a
generic and secure defense technique is
still an open problem and the future
events research need to address this
realistic threat more seriously yeah if
if we can achieve type safety then the
situation will be much better but i
think the common common belief is
achieving complete type safety is pretty
challenging task yeah yeah but but but
we we are getting there I think so so we
know that so so we know that we cannot
rely on control flow integrity to build
our defense techniques the the next
question is Oh whether there exists such
a common characteristic among memory
corruption attack that that allows us to
build our defense techniques so in this
part of the talk I will first define a
program behavior called pointer
daintiness and then I will show that
detecting pointer daintiness is a
promising direction towards a better
security protection for real-world
systems now first what is pointer
daintiness pointer tenderness is a
program behavior where a pointer value
including a return address is arrived
from user input now in the next slide I
will show that many many memory
corruption vulnerabilities met many
memory corruption attacks are due to
pointer daintiness which allows the user
to arbitrarily specify the memory
location to read write and transfer
control to this pointer tenderness
usually is a pathological program
behavior caused by security attack and
that the strength of of the notion of
pointer tankiness is that it's provide a
unifying perspective for reasoning about
many security attacks including
including a format string attack stack
buffer overflow attack keep corruption
and globbing attacks so now I will show
a few examples of this maybe I think the
most widely known widely known attack is
stack buffer overflow where I have I
have a stack buffer with 100 bite then
when the program costs string copy the
user input can exceed the boundary to
override frame pointer and the return
address so that in other words the root
cause is it's because brain pointer or
return address can be tainted then a
more complicated example is formats
during attack so here I have a piece of
code to read read a stream from socket
and the print out of this stream
although the correct invocation of print
F should be % s but and and this is an
instance of format string attack which
allows the attacker to overwrite an
arbitrary memory location in this case I
will show you how to overwrite the
memory location aap BCC TD but the only
thing the attacker need to do is to send
this string to the buffer which is
placed on the step and then when print F
is called eventually a trial function V
F printf will be involved and in VF
printf there are two pointers the first
is the the format screen pointer to scan
through the entire format string and
another pointer is AP
the argument pointer to scan through the
argument list corresponding to the
formatted directives so there are many
details in formatted string attack but
the most crucial effect is that when FMT
points to % n AP happens to point to
this word which specified by me so so
the behavior of v VF printf is that
whenever whenever FMT points to % n then
start star AP equals character counts so
effectively this statement is star star
hey BB CC DD equals character count
which allows you to write a value to a
memory address specified by the user so
the root cause of format string attack
is because star AP is a tainted value
which is dereference so another example
is that the internal of heap corruption
attack is because so the the free memory
trunks are organized in the invite that
the heat management system as a doubly
linked list so in this case free Jack P
has a forward links to a and a bad word
link to see now for if for any reason
that are these links can be tainted by
user value now then when the allocated
buffer path is freed these two
statements will be executed so so now we
know that if b FD and the bpk are
tainted then the effect of 3 is to write
a piece of user input but a piece of
data from user input to the memory
address specified by user input so
basically you can write an arbitrary
value to an arbitrary memory location
this this is a severe memory corruption
now we have seen
so many real examples of pointer
daintiness now that the question is are
how can we build defense techniques to
defeat to to defeat these attacks so in
the rest part of the talk i would like
to our discuss two techniques the first
is a static code analysis technique to
formally reason about the pointer
daintiness in order to extract the
conditions under which such possibility
exists and that the purpose the goal is
to uncover potential vulnerabilities the
other technique is a runtime detection
technique to monitor at runtime where
the attentive al you is referenced as
pointer so this is to defeat memory
corruption attacks we in this project we
develop us a theorem proving based
analysis technique to formally reason
about pointer daintiness currently this
technique is used to extract security
specifications of library functions so
we found that a significant portion of
security vulnerabilities are due to
incorrect invocations of library
functions which means we need a more
rigorous reasoning about library
function specifications however
currently library function
specifications are specified empirically
but for example now in we know format
string attack so now it is clear that
printf the first argument should not be
a user-specified string and a string
copy the the sauce buffers should not
exceed the boundary of the destination
buffer and these two buffer cannot
overlap cannot overlap and free up when
you free a buffer this p should be
should be obtained from our previous
malik and
also P cannot be be freed before etc so
every every function seem to have quite
different specification now the question
is what is the unified reason why these
specifications are required but based on
the notion of pointer daintiness the
answer is very simple they are they are
required to eliminate pointer daintiness
now this is I think this is a very
interesting observation because now the
extraction of security specification of
a function is reduced to a theorem
proving task we basically only need to
to to reason about the conditions under
which pointer tightness exists so so in
this project we use a theorem prover to
to analyze the code to in order to
extract such specifications and the
benefit of formal and complete
specification is that it it allows
compiler techniques to check application
source code for security the basis of
the the basis of the theorem proving
technique is a formal definition of
programming semantics so currently we
use we we define the semantics using an
equation or logic framework but due to
time constraints I'm not able to show
the equation or definitions of often
semantics but basically basically we are
defined to set of equations the first
set defines daintiness aware memory
model where we define the two operations
to fetch the content and test the
tainted needs of each memory location
and then the second set of equations are
incorporate the notion of pointer
daintiness into program semantics for
example we we define the semantics of
load store and
are you instructions in order to
propagate tetanus from our source data
to destination data and also we define
the semantics of input functions like
scanf receive and receive from two to
initially taint them the memory
locations so now having the formal
semantics this is the flow of theater
improving technique the first a piece of
that the sea source code of the library
function is automatically translated to
its former our semantic representation
then for each each pointer dereference
in an assignment we need to generate a
theorem stating that the the pointer
should not be tainted so we get up on a
bunch of theorems in this stage then
finally we use the theorem prover to
prove the validity of the theorems so
either these are these theorems can be
proved which means which means the
library function is secure
unconditionally all these theorems
cannot be proved by the theorem prover
in that case the theorem prover will
suggest a set of sufficient conditions
that imply the validity of the theorems
so those those are conditions are the
security specifications of the analyzed
function which which shows that as long
as these conditions are satisfied then
this function is secure exactly the the
security specifications now here is an
example of VF printf in in this part are
in the program there are two pointer
dereferences in the code in the
assignment statement corresponding to
the first one we need to prove that path
class n should not be attainted value
and the corresponding to the second one
we need to prove that huge should not be
attained
value then we we tried to use the
theorem prover to prove these theorems
but initially we cannot establish the
proof because the two theorems are only
valid under certain preconditions then
what we do is to add these three
conditions as axioms to the theorem
prover and repeat this step until both
the herbs are proved finally we found
that pause for preconditions are added
to the theorem prover which are the
security specifications of VF printf so
the these are the the extracted security
specifications which means if these if
all these are satisfied then VF printf
is secure and an interesting observation
is the last one which state that no
locations within ap activity range are
tainted before VF print have is called
that this AP activity range is the the
memory location that the AP sweep over
so this this specification exactly
indicated the scenario of the format
string vulnerability that I I just show
you before in a previous slide I'm sorry
okay so the the IU's theorem prover so
the theorem prover is currently not
completely automatic tool it is but it
substantially help you to go through the
complicated form or reasoning process it
really are very helpful and the the
theorem proving process is is a inter
interactive process so using similar
technique we analyze string copy where
we we extract specifications indicating
buffer overflow but for overlapping and
the power underflow scenarios and to
analyze the function free of a
simplified heap management system we
extract security specifications
indicating heap corruption vulnerability
and we also use this formal reasoning to
to analyze the socket socket reader
functions of apache and and the third
party HTTP server where we we can we can
prove that the Apache function is free
of pointer daintiness and and two
vulnerabilities are exposed in the
theorem proving process of this third
party server function so it so so I have
shown that formal reasoning of pointer
daintiness allows allows us to expose
potential security vulnerabilities and
in this project we develop a runtime
pointer daintiness detection technique
to defeat memory corruption attacks so
this this is basically a processor
architecture level of mechanism to TT to
detect pointer daintiness so the idea is
exactly same as our previous paper but
the only difference is this is a runtime
detection technique and it is not based
on fear improving
etic static analysis but the goal of our
of this project is to show that it is to
show the validity of pointer daintiness
concept on whole programs of real
applications so we we run a many network
servers and respect 2000 integer
benchmarks on this modified by the way
that this is implemented on simple
scalar simulator and so we we evaluate
the effectiveness of detection by using
both control control data attack and non
control data attack and we found that
both attacks are detected in the
uniformed way because from the
standpoint of pointer daintiness these
two types of attacks are are not
different both are pointer daintiness
attacks we did not find any false alarm
in the application evaluated which means
well whenever there is no attack there
is no alarm another advantage of the
another advantage of the technique is
the transparency to applications and we
can run free compiled binaries on this
processor not modify the processor but
there could be a small number of
potential attack scenarios undetected
however we we argue that these scenarios
are really very rare and they are not
defeated by any current any current
generic protection techniques so based
on this evaluation we we conclude that
point eight Internet's detection can be
applied to the whole program of real
software which offers a substantial
improvement of security protection
the the impact on performance so right
now this this is implemented as at the
processor level so we we assume that
this this works pretty well in parallel
with the current architecture so so we
think the performance overhead should
not be very big but we haven't done very
extensive analysis on this
correct okay so that that I only I only
modify the system called the receiving
system call which is implemented in
simple scalar
yeah yes yes so I so I think yeah so
currently the a challenge of this
technique is how can you convince for
example in tell people to do this
because you need a different memory
model so that should be hopefully it
should be addressed in my future future
research
yeah parity bit yes
so so but the the the goal of that
project is to to test the concept that a
pointer tenderness concept can be
applied to two real large piece of code
the whole program off of real code and
including network servers FTP servers
now so now I reach to my conclusion we
have shown that many real-world software
can be compromised by corrupting non
control data so therefore it is
insufficient to rely on control flow
integrity for software security then on
the other hand we found that pointer
tenderness is unifying perspective for
to reason about most memory corruption
vulnerabilities and attacks and we we
argue that reasoning about the pointer
tenderness is a promising direction to
enhance security on real-world systems
to demonstrate this we developed a
theorem proving based code analysis
technique and runtime pointed into this
detection technique to defeat most
memory corruption attacks and i think
that the current state of my research is
a good good basis and i would like to
extend it by providing a higher degree
of automation for the theorem proving
technique because it is come to be a lot
of interactions and also to reduce the
intrusiveness of a runtime pointer
detection appointed internets detection
technique hopefully by combining these
two techniques I hopefully I do not need
the extra bit because if I can reason
about the preconditions of each function
then the architecture can can only check
the validity of the preconditions
without the extra bit that this is the
hope and for long-term goes I think
there are a number of interesting
directions the first is to extract
programming styles are susceptible to
secure
the attacks so for example we observe
that a big problem in current
programming practice is the the long
lifetime of security security critical
data so how how can compilers detect the
such bad programming styles in order to
mitigate the security impact then to
identify a broader range of
non-traditional security threat and to
study historical data about how security
vulnerabilities were discovered reported
and patched to see how house
successfully we did in in the past and
what should we do in that in the future
another very interesting thing I'd like
to do is to decompose the behaviors of
virus worms and rootkit to a not a
number of basic building blocks so as
you can see that in my study I tried to
decompose security vulnerabilities to a
number of building blocks and that
really helped me to think of what is the
maximum capability of attackers whether
the attacker how the attacker can
reassemble polymorphic attacks to
understand what what is the real threat
to our systems and finally I'd like to I
have a few words about my research
methodology as I said in my first slide
that the uniqueness of my research is
the analysis centric approach I spend a
significant amount of effort in my
dissertation on our analysis of real
data so the the methodology is to start
from reality to define the problems and
I really like this methodology and I
like to analyze real data and the real
instances and sometimes I have to say it
is tedious but I I believe this is a
step towards a lot of fun in research
and also it is
definitely rewarding especially for
systems research and I think that the
eventual goal is to strongly motivated
research topics that solve problems in
the reality so this is this concludes my
talk I'm sorry aha you know to to
automate the property of functions to
automatically to automatically extract
the specification oh yeah so that is
what I was trying to show by by
reasoning about pointer tightness we can
extract a lot of security specifications
but that's this answer 18
yeah so I i think the exciting
excitement if i can get the job then
then the other thing is I think a PPR
see is definitely a very strong team in
this type of research so they they can
find I'll they are very strong in formal
reasoning and compiler techniques but I
think then the input I can put in into
their technique is I i show that what to
check what should be the starting point
that that you can build your formal
reasoning on top of that and this thing
in my dissertation I think pointer
tenderness is a property that is it is
critical to check so I think so too to
automatically our reasoning about this
we need to take the direction similar to
ppic direction like model checking like
a clear improving that type of things
no not that that no no no no no no so my
contribution is basically the extensive
analysis which which tells you what to
check what is the critical program
behavior that can pretty much our usual
security thank you very much
yeah lunch